[Musique]
poétique
tranchante
la mère façonnent l'imaginaire
polynésiens et nourrit ses légendes
autrefois une princesse chevaucher les
bacs avec une grâce inégalée à en rendre
jaloux les rois
elle s'élançait sur la pluie terrible de
toute la vague de teahupoo
[Musique]
aujourd'hui une jeune femme se mesure de
nouveau à l
solaire déterminée elle s'appelle vahiné
fierro à 21 ans elle est déjà championne
du monde
elle veut écrire sa propre légende à
teahupoo malgré des risques
je
sous une vague tu peux rester maximum 15
secondes maximum mais juste cinq
secondes sous une grosse vague c'est
comme dans une machine à rabaisser pas
calme j'étais en cumulant jeter dans la
vague tu te fais emporté tu te fait tilt
et d'amp tu paies beaucoup d'oxygène
quand tu es dans une situation
de fait peur de pouvoir garder ce cas là
bas ça va te permettre de pouvoir civil
on a quelques sols il faut juste rester
comme
teahupoo accueillera pour la première
fois les épreuves olympiques en 2024
au pied de ces montagnes dans le sillage
de vahiné toute une génération se
prépare à réécrire l'histoire du surf au
féminin
[Musique]
beaucoup
m
[Musique]
il
j'ai fait ma décision
si c'est le spa tous les vents glacés un
peu moins creuses et elle ça super lent
et super fun donc c'est un peu ici qu'on
a qu'on appuie con qu'on était à l'aise
et qu'on s'amusait beaucoup car c'est
difficile
enfin au début on s'amusait beaucoup est
plutôt de la commencer à utiliser
ensuite c'était un peu plus technique
appelée par les voulait pas les seuls il
fallait pas qu'elle touche le récit
points donc c'était stressant à chaque
fois donc du commun sous la poussée moi
je me mettais à l'intérieur qu'il a
récupéré le sud et voilà ça les rassure
et enfin on a fait ça avec les pros donc
on a passé beaucoup de temps dans l'eau
savoureuse s'amuser c'est vraiment petit
prince pontal ci a touché le site
internet je l'appelle la cession comme
bout desquels nous on voulait
[Musique]
ma maman est là
c'est la meilleure façon de vivre je
pense être proche de la nature
ça rend les gens et les autres
ben nous on est tout le temps écoulé je
la mets donc défend des fois on devient
un peu des fois on apprécie même plus
alors qu en fait et c'est quand on quand
on peut plus y aller quand on est
coincés dans les aéroports c'est là que
tu viens à lisbonne c'est l'un des
meilleurs moments s'est passée dans
l'eau entre eux si on entend même tout
seul
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon
c'est vrai que avec tous les voyages que
j'ai faits et nous ticket à l'école chi
vinh avril la famille elle est un peu
plus et parler maintenant il est décoré
se retrouver je tiens à les compenser
les voyages mais on revient tout ici et
après on se fait des petites sessions
comme ça va tous ensemble pas marrant
c'est pas un montage de vivre c'est
vraiment estimant toutes les trois dans
l'eau et j'espère que ça va rester comme
ça tous là c'est l'enfant parce que j'ai
pas donné à tout le monde de ce fait sa
personne et ouais c'est vrai moi je
pense avocats de la planète
et
[Musique]
à
la maison
[Musique]
mais c'est ici que j'ai grandi et c'est
le paradis sur terre
toutes les maisons c'est mon papa qui
apprécient la caisse et john c c'est
lucas design et
vahiné c'est son prénom
il signifie femme en tahitien
vahiné c'est aussi une image créée par
les récits des explorateurs européens
celle d'une fille des îles douce et
indolente
bien loin des jeunes polynésienne
aujourd'hui
car c'est louche plateau
[Musique]
en fait mon papa il est des états unis
et
dans cette vallée
je cherchais des bananes des avocats
plus bas dans la vallée
[Musique]
je vois cette femme arrivée dans ma
direction sur son cheval qui galope de
travers
je ne savais pas galoper normalement été
complètement fou
tu avec son cheval j'ai su que c'était
la femme de ma vie
depuis que j'ai commencé le surf j'étais
pas vraiment destinée je pense a été une
compétitrice et c'est quand mon papa a
vu que j'avais un peu le niveau il était
là à peut-être que tu devrais essayer
faire une compétition et moi je dirais
que j'ai un peu bloquée je les dis non
j'aime pas trop ce côté là où il ya une
pression il ya pas de mon point de vue
il ya une pelisse y entend limiter
fallait que je m'exprime bits et donc je
n'aimais pas trop l'idée mais je me suis
dit bon je vais quand même essayer parce
que en fait c'est quand même un métier
de rêve de pouvoir le fais ce que tu
aimes tant ce temps sport préféré de
pratique et ça et d'être payé pour ça
donc je me suis dit bon ça peut y être
pas moi
c
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas que
j'essaie fait les planches ne manquera
pas jusqu'à l'âge de 17 ans donc voilà
j'aime bien de temps en temps vinyle et
après on a peu avec lui comme on fait
quelques tu
veux les voir
la planche que vous voyez là où
avec la petite sirène dessiné par ma
femme c'est la toute première planche de
vahiné avec une seule des risques elle a
tout appris sur celle larzac une planche
recyclé avec les matériaux que je
pouvais trouver ici à tahiti
ensuite
il ya celle-ci vahiné commencé sur le
circuit qualificatif des championnats du
monde elle avait terminé deuxième sur le
spot de 'pipeline' hawaii
tout jouer ça s'est heurté à une
première place
désolé pour
bajarin ça c'est un tournant dans la
carrière de vanoise
là elles commençaient vraiment enchaîner
les bons résultats plus seulement chez
les juniors mais aussi chez les plus de
18 ans c'était une très bonne année et
là on s'est dit on prend le bon chemin
je ne sais même pas si on a déjà dit
qu'elle allait faire carrière
au début c'était juste une passion
et puis elle a commencé à avoir de bons
résultats sans vraiment chercher à
devenir une championne
je les ai vus aux compétitions il ya peu
de temps et vous savez quoi j'étais
scotché par son intelligence
pour elle le surf c'est comme une partie
d'échecs il y un timing un choix de
vagues une météo des figures
et maintenant elle est capable de
déchiffrer l'océan de se dire ok je peux
gagner grâce à cette vallée je vais y
arriver
j'ai commencé à fait les compétitions
mais c'était un autre monde il fallait
un peu changé la façon dont j'allais
fallait c'était un peu fallait prendre
un peu plus sérieusement si je voulais
progresser et j'avais le choix ma maman
m'avait donné le chantre fait l'écho la
mise en reste et chevronnés ou partir et
j'ai décidé de partir parce qu'il ya une
section surf au lycée de papara et pour
pouvoir je pense pêche c'est dans le
sèche mais il fallait que je parte il
fallait que je quitte mon île
[Musique]
oui
on est tout le temps super proches et
ouais je demande tout le temps de le
peindre sur ses planches ou dessiner
aussi la peur pour toi mais je te la
maison quand tu étais assez jeune ouais
j'avais
j'avais 10 ans quand elle est partie et
c'est a été traité du web 2 ça a été
vraiment vraiment vraiment dur quel pas
comme ça
je pense que ses côtés où je suis parti
à un jeune âge bassam ça m'a ouvert
plein de portes et ça m'a ouvert
l'esprit ça m'a permis d'être de me
débrouiller tout seul donc moi je
c'était la meilleure décision in 2001
décision que j'ai jamais fait
la surfeuse de vous animez aux anges
akiyama en australie c'est cette
dernière compétition junior en ville et
pierrot et croches le titre tant
convoité de champion du monde une belle
récompense après cinq années de
sacrifices la reconnexion elle était là
avec l'océan avec toutes les personnes
qui était l'âme souteniez j'ai tout
allait dans mon sens même si j'essayais
de faire le contraire ben et la vague et
revenez je pouvais faire à chaque fois
je sais pas comment expliquer parce que
c'est comme s'il y avait une connexion
tout au long de la journée où tout s'est
passé comme il fallait c'était un peu
comme la rive je me suis pas vraiment
rendu compte que j'avais gagné jusqu'à
ce que j'arrive ici à paris
[Musique]
j'ai demandé où je pouvais mettre mon
trophée ils m'ont dit juste à côté de
moi même été lui la ceinture
[Musique]
venue pro que vous aimeriez trop vers la
kaaba l on a été capable elle est donc
pourquoi pas nous et puis de la voix
voyage au temps ça me faisait rêver
aussi et c'est dit ouais ben nous avait
faire la même chose et puis parfois moi
aussi j'étais à fond surtout pas parce
que ça va papa il voulait être surfeurs
pros quand j'étais plus jeune il a été
mis sauf que il s'est blessé donc il a
dû arrêter et quand elle a vu que mes
filles sont intéressés vague
que ce soit aussi but un
bon
du coup il ya encore de la peinture ah
ouais c'est aux pêcheurs
et ses amis nos mains ou trois
[Musique]
films comme la dernière
il ya beaucoup d'armes dans notre
famille et ça s'est mis 5 et on est un
peu fou fou
[Musique]
[Rires]
bout de la route desservant la côte
ouest de la presqu'île de tahiti au tour
car vos un village santé tension
pourtant sa réputation a fait le tour du
monde grâce à la vague qui se forment à
l'entrée de la parade est situé en face
du village
vous disent que c'est la gauche confie
une vague qui part vers la gauche ou la
plus radicale au monde
[Musique]
toujours quelque chose d'incroyable qui
se passe à tshopo c'est ça qui est
magique avec cette vague c'est le graal
pour les surfers parce que c'est le
sport le surfeur c'est le tube la
manoeuvre rennes et tshopo délivre un
tube pratiquement à chaque vague est un
tube intense court et surtout
fascinant photographe yable d'un bateau
on ne peut pratiquement d'un bateau on
peut voir le surfeur pratiquement sûr
tout sur tout
la vague qu'elle est parfaite ah ça fait
un film oui c'est pour ça que c'est
devenu une vague aussi connu aussi
photogénique
[Musique]
et pas que mais là aussi terrifiant pour
plein de gens travaillent pour moi pour
tout le monde y à peine un mètre de
doper donc si on tombe à cet endroit là
elle est la probabilité de contre tous
le récif est assez grande donc si on
tombe qu'est-ce qui se passe non cela
sert
les pieds les jambes ou des coupures de
corail quoi puisque la cdu corail donc
en général si on tombe au mauvais
endroit alors soit on est pris dans le
roman soit on tape le récit fait là bas
ça peut être les coups à la tête n'a pas
droit à l'erreur sur scène donc voilà
c'est vrai que
et surtout quand on rame il faut
vraiment pas douter les chutes
spectaculaires ont participé à la
légende de teahupoo comme celle de la
hawaïenne keala kennelly blessé au crâne
durant la compétition annuelle du wct le
tour du monde de surf en 2006 les
épreuves féminines sont supprimés
[Musique]
cette année les championnats du monde
seront de nouveau mixte à teahupoo
les femmes signent leur grand retour à
la compétition sur ce site redoutable
avant le rendez vous olympiques de 2024
vahiné aura la chance d'évoluer à
domicile elle espère en tirer un
avantage
la première fois que je suis venu
c'était même pas que j'étais très
content
la perfectionniste et est assez petit et
j'avais à ses pairs mais c'est l'année
dernière j'ai vraiment commencé à venir
que c'est un peu nigaud et être dans
l'autre c'est un peu de culot
je vais changer de
d'objectifs
depuis qu'on sait que propos et la vague
des jeux olympiques est certainement
l'année prochaine il y aura
doux mais c'était avec les filles on
voit
toutes les meilleures surfaces descendre
mois une semaine ou deux pour produire
s'entraîner ici avec magnifique ça
c'était mon gracié dehors d'une forme si
le céline bracq donc là en plus avec
dargaud ça va être un match parfait
[Musique]
à cannes on assiste pas
je
[Musique]
ça y est
c'est mignon des panneaux
[Musique]
à teahupoo les vagues mesures parfois
jusqu'à 10 mètres dos
seoul monstrueux attire généralement une
nuée de surfeurs locaux et étrangers
rares sont ceux qui osent se lancer
[Musique]
ce matin la vahiné est la seule femme à
se jeter à l'eau
[Musique]
fébrile elle rate son démarrage
la soeur faisait piéger dans la fameuse
machine à laver
impossible d'être récupéré par le jet
ski les vagues se succèdent trop
rapidement
de longues minutes à résister à chercher
son souffle
[Musique]
vahiné sort finalement indemne de cette
chute
[Musique]
et malgré cette frayeur elle décide de
retourner à l'eau quelques heures plus
tard
elle ne le sait pas encore mais sa
prochaine vague entrera dans l'histoire
du surf
quand on est retourné sa veste grossir
quand j'étais là et j'étais passé et je
me suis dit bon ok une vague et
et du coup je me suis mise à l'eau et ça
m'a pris une heure où j'ai attendu la
vague parce que j'avais un peu peur
parce qu'il y avait des grosses séries
et si je me mettais à l'atelier j'en ai
peut-être ramassis ses villas donc à un
moment donné ça a été appelée l'accalmie
il s'est tu vas y arriver et la fin j'ai
commencé à la mi temps d'y aller van
gogh ou tu dégages quand j'étais la
seule fille ce jeu là tu l'aies gaza les
cobayes me gauvin et la bougeotte en
plus rien puisque vincent lamy et là je
me mets j'ai failli tomber aulas les
verts s est mise et j'ai failli tomber
là j'ai eu le temps d'aimer si élise est
dans la vidéo tu vois que j'aime et si
le visage et après gérer je reste et je
n'étais pas sûr de passer ça faisait que
de lancer que de lancer et là je suis
sortie et il en va avec tout le talent
dans le chenal qui avait entre autres
qui applaudissait
avec cette vague elle obtient le prix du
plus beau tube féminin de l'année
c'est la première en fait tahitienne
avoir un tel niveau
il ya deux trois autres surfeuse qui
sauf tshopo 1 mètre 50
ou peut-être un peu plus gros mais c'est
la seule qui a un niveau comme ça
surtout c'est là qu'elle va apprendre à
choisir des débats qui vont tubes et va
faire deux tubes sur la même vague il va
surfer la vague comme une vraie
professionnelle voilà comme les
meilleures surfeuses sur le tour
aujourd'hui elle a des vrais alors que
la 20 ans qu'elle n'a pas fait vraiment
la panne a fait un peu de compétition
mais pas autant que toutes ces filles là
elle a déjà un niveau incroyable
vraiment
d'accord maintenant monaco à lyon au
congo non non la rue championnet
automatique placée là il a des super
banco ccja
c'était en haïti rails
il a vraiment et manquant ses abonnés
la championne leïla était plein
conseil il faut lui donner je n'ai
jamais peur pas mais il ya beaucoup de
mes cendres dans ta vie a peur ou
pourquoi pas
24 championnat les deux là c'est en
poussant
[Rires]
[Musique]
des pas de la femme a dit
l'avocat
[Musique]
je sais même pas que je me suis sans
voix
[Musique]
je vais pas laisser d'espacé à chaque
fois que qui a une grosse houle et que
je sais qu'elles sont là bas je stresse
coin et je suis bien content quand le
soleil se couche et que je sais qu'elles
vont bien
mon papa il était si il a été assez
sévèrement parce que j'avais peur et
donc souvent
ils étaient plus très du coup
ea mobile est souvent parce que je
sortais pas ma petite salle elle était
déjà au pic mes copines j'étais tout au
piquet et ça ça a énormément pas parce
qu'ils savaient que j'avais le potentiel
d'y aller
on a fait un parcours parce que j'ai
jamais cru qu'un jour elle allait se
ficher poupe parce que étant petit elle
avait tout le temps peu des grosses
vannes ça lui a mis beaucoup de temps
pour arriver au pays que l'avant surf
d'habitude et voilà comme et maintenant
elle en est là et c'est impressionnant
on a fait du chemin
mais vahiné aller comme ça quand elle
veut quelque chose le fond ce coin
[Musique]
s'exclame
m
[Musique]
magnifique moi aussi j'avais les cheveux
je faisais pour ça fait les cheveux
lâchés les chaînes moi jamais c'était
l'époque ça et moi j'avais 15 ans 74 61
tonnes ont
été pris avec elle comme je voyais quels
moyens et puis
alors je me suis mise au surf
parce que j'ai trouvé que toutes les
nanas et passaient leur temps à attendre
le mec dans leur bagnole
je dis moi c'est pas moi qui vais faire
ça tant que je me suis mise aux soeurs
et je disais à tout le monde si vous
voulez me vois je suis au surf quoi et
donc c'est comme ça aussi que je suis me
suy bi s'est appelée bon c'est vrai que
quand tu commences à te lever
et puis quand tu vois que tu surf et
bien tu deviens comme on dit addict
alors tu y vas tu penseurs fait tous les
soirs tu dors surf et tu ta vie c'est
que du seul et ce n'est pas trop dur
d'être la seule fille à l'eau
à cette époque là il y avait de la
courtoisie
[Musique]
à cette époque là le surf ne s'est pas
encore démocratisée
et surfeurs sont peu nombreux et souvent
considérés comme marginaux
ils sont en réalité les héritiers d'une
pratique ancestrale
trois cents ans plus tôt les navigateurs
européens débarque en polynésie ils sont
les premiers à décrire des hommes et des
femmes capables de se tenir debout sur
la planche jusqu'à ce que la vague
bridge
les tahitiens appelle cela le vau l'eau
[Musique]
mais bientôt les missionnaires
protestants viennent bouleverser la
culture locale les évangélistes
désapprouvent cette pratique et les
femmes sont éclipsés de son histoire
[Musique]
elles apparaissent pourtant dans les
légendes anciennes transmise par la
tradition orale
[Musique]
m
c'est l'histoire de veille à tous et
une princesse originaire de raiatea
extraordinairement doué pour
glisser sur les vagues pour s'emparer de
leurs forces et être projeté par elle
crée loin
il se trouve que le roi de l'endroit où
elle aime justement profiter de la force
des vagues hachiro
il n'est jaloux de sa célébrité
[Musique]
c'est en moi qui ai tellement
elle môme
dpt de l'ascendant qu'elle prend sur ce
qu'il observe qu'il prend son mot pour
capter son pouvoir
ces gens dansent les transmet ou se la
raconte ouais c'est tout à fait tout à
fait et joue il avait les jambes qui
montrent la présence des femmes dans
exactement
exactement et donc il s'est
véritablement la preuve que ça n'est pas
voilà la sphère de femmes
particulièrement cranie ou non c'est
qu'il y avait véritablement une mixité
dans les les activités
touchant à la mer et puis surtout c'est
que visiblement enfin depuis la nuit des
temps les femmes sont ivres sur les
vagues
[Musique]
quand je vais me balader sur les spots
pour emmener ma fille faire du bruit
c'est hallucinant je suis même étonnée
qu'il ya des fois il ya des spots où il
ya cinquante qu'on s'endorme et 50% 30
c'est parce que maintenant les femmes
sont vachement plus respectées elles ont
moins peur etc c'est devenu une
communauté à part entière enfin je dis à
mes mails et surfer groupe et elles sont
vachement plus respectés par les hommes
parce que il ya eu des femmes avant
qu'ils ont montrés que
pouvait être respectée parce que on
avait le même talent on avait ont surfé
les grossman ont surfé le récif on avait
peur de rien on toucher à tout et
on s'est fait respecter nous à ce moment
là il ya vingt ans et
et maintenant je dirais que c'est
beaucoup plus facile pour les filles qui
arrivent elles ont presque le respect
des dès le départ
voilà c'est ça
on la place ouais je sais
catégorie open yes ça c'est open femme à
la presse à ces jeux du pacifique ils
ont été médaillés des jeux du pacifique
ta poule un master j'ai eu une dizaine
de victoires je crois
je vais pas me vanter mais je crois
qu'au niveau des championnats polynésie
au niveau des performances au niveau
local je crois avoir été celle qui a le
plus de titres c'est comme ça j'en ai
gardé
j'en ai gardé quelques unes c'était à
l'époque où les filles faisait de
zschopau moi j'ai fait trois quatre fois
la couverture du magazine c'est un peu
comme télé 7 jours chez vous quoi les
photographes étaient vachement patient
avec moi c'est bon moi j'étais la
surfeuse un peu
garçon manqué parce qu'aujourd'hui il
faut être
maintenant c'est si on veut être à 100%
l'égérie d'une marque il faut être bon
surf et il faut présenter il faut être
féminin il faut savoir être égérie d'une
marque c'est représenter les vêtements
quoi donc il faut savoir les porter ça
fait l'unité du coup c'est la façon
d'avoir de l'argent
maintenant c'est ouais c'est 50 50 mais
il faut du lifestyle il faut du twitter
il faut d'une stade g il faut voilà
c'est ça qui marche maintenant il faut
que ce soit vu par tous et pour que ce
soit vu faut que ce soit beau à voir
[Musique]
je vous présente la nouvelle génération
je tenais personnes ou d'entreprises et
les cp foot c'est que deux c'est une
chance et ça va être la cuisine une
option de plus pour moi ça me titille
mawazine qui aragones
[Musique]
l'allemand
eilat années 80
quand le corps
massages et auch
ah les grandes grandes matières
par la tempête il ya repris 7 6 y en a
l'habitude mais toi tu veux devenir plus
fort au sénat
qu'est ce qui t'a donné envie de faire
ça
c'est vache échappée qu'elle vit quand
j'ai vu les vagues
déferlant la voyante elle que tu as eu
envie de suivre ses pas vraiment
donc à dire des parents je vais être
mieux
[Musique]
mais souvent elles arrivent à bon mois
elle arrive à un moment le matin quand
j'arrive là pour les entraînements mais
elle est déjà là avec sa propre et
elmaleh très motivés
vas-y avox à votre avis combien
d'abonnés là du coup
[Musique]
elle est là elle est grosse en
voici la compta feliz tonnes ha
on allait avec en tentant des mae
vengea btf quand j'ai vu les vagues mais
je voulais s'est passé m'a fait et où je
suis allée une double du temps on peut
forcer les et ça valait le coup parce
que les gars de la ville avant de la
journée elle est grande régate ça fait
trois fois rien ouais c'est même moi je
dis 35 ans
senna le
japon compte twitter by
et c'est important d'avoir un compte
instagram quand on est pro sortis au 1er
mai je pense que c'est important aussi
pas l'apologie sponsors par rapport aux
médias c'est important de bien que les
gens voient pas ce que tu fais et ça
s'est passé dans la nouvelle c'est la
nouvelle façon de s'identifier aussi
dans le monde d'avoir de la convaincante
sur les réseaux sociaux et je pense que
c'est important de bien gérer ça pour le
poulet sommes seuls
papa elle a fait l ohlala 10.6 pin vague
tu imagines va bien c'est très sympa
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors inventant 4 1 qui fera l'éloge ou
le glam
vu des thématiques
[Musique]
voilà là c'est bon
ces cathos
une chute
dip aux parents de finir le tout un art
amitié
hélas
la
vague
non
ce bâtiment
3.6 a pas trois pompes situe shit pompe
connaît la grèce
ça fait partie de l'entraînement
et bêtement capitaux et apprend qu'on a
minci temps tu vois ta part à quatre
points qu'il était bon
tu tentes ne s'était pas
ok allez
c'est dingue quand on va aider à
démarrer
c'est clair et net que ça les différents
elle était déjà vu quand même comme une
fille qui était qu'ils avaient du
potentiel énorme pour le
pas pour la section uniquement pour la
polynésie
[Applaudissements]
je pense que amy tu y es à me continuer
de faire la bête ce n'est pas de sa
faute
en tout cas on l'espère et puis on fera
tout pour que
puis se faire parler comme ça
[Musique]
bah
est ce que n'ont plus de sens
ils ont plus longtemps
ah ben si on parle de sponsoring c'est
clair que les filles elles ont un
avantage elles ont deux deux
opportunités c'est d'apprendre à sa
fille et même si elles savent pas bien
mais à son joli un peu tout juste été
sponsorisés ou si elle a les deux tant
mieux alors là c'est double
donc le contrat donc c'est important
disposera d'assez important pour tout le
monde c'est c'est ce qui ce qui permet
de voyager c'est ce qui permet de
continuer à aller plus loin et de
continuer à vivre c'est ressembler c'est
donc sans sponsor son partenaire ben en
fait rien on la stoppe haïti et puis
voilà on cherche du travail comme tout
le monde on travaille dans les bureaux
les cailloux elle détaille où on est
à
17 environ ouais
ouais beaucoup moins quand même mais
ouais moi je marque tant les points
glanés blendecquois je suis entré dans
la section je m'attendais à ce que la
seule fille parce que je connaissais pas
beaucoup de filles qui vainquit sophie
et puis des vies et moi je les
connaissais pas trop et puis quand j'ai
vu qu'à signer dans la section j'étais
contente aussi ça me motivait de voir
qu'ils avaient d'autres filles aussi
[Musique]
et
dans les faits
[Musique]
et
souvent quand on parle de tahiti pense
que on vit sur un caillou qu'il ya rien
qui a vraiment rien quand on parle de
tahiti sont là mais vous avez des
magasins
vous avez des aéroports vous avez les
voitures là bas louis arti voiture oui
il ya des magasins on a tout ce qu'il
faut et on n'a pas aussi tôt de choses
on sait pas
ban a pas tout
les super
aigle en paix je sais juste que tu vas
pas comme des bonnes choses
c'est patrick est d'accord on arrive à
différents
différentes façons de penser et
donc moi c'est poussé par ce genre de
chose qui m'intéresse moi j'adore le
chef et
il va coiffer tichy donc pourquoi donc
pas moi je vous dis papa j'ai fait mes
études ayé pouvoir du changement du
salut fis quelques défalquer fils ah oui
de passoire avec nos amis les provinces
authority bien savez tout mickaël tout
aux non j'ai pas envie c'était rester là
en mai ténue ah bah tant pis je viens
pas
allez c'est
pas vrai il ya pas de vagues ce qui est
très rare à savoir lundi si on parle pas
que j'aime bien mais bon
ça fait appris qu'elle vit avec nous du
coup on peut être champion de surf et
avoir un petit gamin
si je pense et
je pense comme mécano en
j'aime pas trop ce point de vue ne pas
avoir de copains même si tu sais pas ça
change à rien d'avoir un coût par abri
way dans les coupes y en a le groupe
indien non tu vas voir ça fait ça y est
s'il te dis ça une fois c'est bon tu le
lâchage tiendra devant pour qu'ils
acceptent que le surf est avant tout
ouïe passage passé si j'avais un copain
je pense que
là on est sur la même
pas comment les activités donc je pense
[Rires]
[Musique]
compétition de la fédération passion
excisée à l'ennemi je pense et on aime
bien aller t'entraîner l'an quarante
cinq minutes juste avant comme ça on est
on est chauffée et on n'y prête pas
mais quand tu as dû gut a pris en avion
à exprès pour unir chablis et manta est
appelée bachelet de joie plus à fait à
trois et
que la plupart se
blesse pas je pense que c'est moi ou
c'est le projet de ma faute
[Musique]
au début j'étais toute petite
compétition il y avait vraiment on ça
fait quand les gars en face il y avait
aucune fille qui voulait y participer à
part moi et me thierry marigny lundi
commence à fréquenter les garçons et
c'était c'était autre chose à ne savais
que tu dégages censé messti s'était pas
marché mais bien moi
moi je pense que les filles font
vraiment si vous voulez quelque chose
pour aller jusqu'au bout et il faut pas
s'arrêter juste à cause de quelques gens
quelques garçons qui étaient 10 en
entente et une fille tu peux pas fait ça
ça franchement faut vraiment s'en
foutent de ce que les gens disent ce
genre de commentaires ça veut rien dire
[Applaudissements]
ah ben cohen à la laïcité voilà c'est
comme ça c'est déjà arrivé dans votre
pass est bien que c'est pas bien mais je
pensais bien aussi qu elle passe à la
poussa le samedi dans la vie des ces
poussées pis d'accès à
80 ans
vous
tous les jours en algérie
[Musique]
il a douze des 45 secondes
de plus
après coup dur on dîne à la troisième
place cielo et miti
à la deuxième place si le combat et
je pense que j'ai fais beaucoup mes
petites soeurs elles sont pour le moment
sous mon ongle et il faut qu'elle fasse
quelque chose qui les démarque de deux
mois est donc en quelque sorte sans les
pousse à devoir faire mieux que moi eh
ben je suis peut-être ou de la plus
grande motivation à devoir progression
s'est fait de pouvoir devant se pousser
dans ce qu'elles font
j'ai terminé 3e n'est pas très bien sûr
fait vraiment pas bien
j'avais besoin d'un 5 pour gagner mais
j'ai eu seulement des 4
on a plein qui font cette heure-là de
jeudi là on va être plus elles ont
abandonné l'école et on va faire que ça
on va fait que chez hp ont affecté son
pays on va se focaliser que sur scène
sauf que c'est pas très réaliste parce
que les normes de places sont tellement
limité qu'il y a il n'y a pas beaucoup
de chances que tu te qualifies klein et
justement elle vous met en garde sur les
difficultés à être pro ex tu vas voir
c'est les est en voie communale il m'a
bien fait rire des bonbons ou louer le
temps pour donner à sa rivale c'est
toutes les ficelles c'est comme ça avec
les gars semblent je suis chez le compte
à rebours des fêtes de maculer
maintenant on n'en peut plus et a qu'une
envie celle abandonnée téléphone
[Musique]
ou
que
[Musique]
on
le couple
[Musique]
depuis qu'on en polynésie ya un mot
qu'on a entendu plusieurs fois c'est mon
mana est ce que tu pourrais nous dire ce
que c est ce que ça représente aussi le
mois le moins là c'est une forme
d'énergie que tu le trouves en polynésie
et s'est tu quand on m'a là où tu le
crois pas mais moi je suis une grande
croyante ansa et d'ariège s'étant donné
que je fais assez souvent le matin tôt
pour arriver avant le lever du soleil eh
ben c'est là seulement donné où je
ressens une énorme l'énergique que
j'allais pas le trouver ailleurs et je
sais pas c'est un peu une énergie que tu
que c'est un peu personnel en fait c'est
toi qui la planche ou pas mais
c'est c'est un tube c'est une énergie
que tu peux pas tellement expliqué c'est
juste un ressentiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça c'était mon deuxième ce taux est
appelé à plus de jetons pas plus ça
c'est magnifique et mais c'est
incroyable
[Rires]
comme ça à temps g
c'est incroyable c'est là bas il fait
pas très beau mais même quand il fait
pas beau c'est magnifique
j'adore les moments qui me font sentir
vivante donc dès que ça demande un peu
défaut elle est bien c'est là que ça
commence à m'intéresser et voilà c'est
jade moment là où tu dans fait tout
uniment tg je quitte en cette aube on a
un cutter 4h30 et donc c'est quand même
assez tôt tu vois pas grand chose en
remontant donc pas tous eu tous ces
éléments-là qui entend juste à plein
fatigue tu vois pas bien et laissez les
meilleurs moments les moments où tu te
suis pas seul et moment t'es pas su les
et qui arrive à 1 s'est passé tout s'est
tu enlèves g20 c'est le meilleurs
sentiments après et là c'est quoi le
prochain challenge le truc que tu
arrives pas encore à faire je pense que
c'est me qualifier c'était et pour les
jeux olympiques 2020 terre et 2004 et
aussi une très grosse vague alors
amateurs ca c je pense que c'est un des
plus grands les deux fait ça parce que
c'est c'est quelque chose qui me qui
m'est fait beaucoup mais je sais qu'une
fois que je vais d ici là cimenter cette
paire est cimentée tous les éléments ben
ça va être le meilleur feeling au monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]